bonjour madame alors voilà on a gagné
mais veut ni cheval il a tâté bloque pas
fois les 3 cm et aussi regardent
commandement famille ils les inrocks pas
rien du tout du coup les besoins se
cogner vous mais c'est la joie oui ils
rendent toujours service parce que après
en ce moment et on part pour arriver à
cette émotion qui atteste de la
pertinence de cette action d'urgence
sociale ce panier on aura fait du chemin
et tout commence à 6 heures du matin
ma vie produit est un peu d'ananas photo
passion dans cette exploitation
familiale de 4 hectares la cueillette se
fait pour les paniers du jour ce sont
les produits des quais quand ils sont
arrivés à maturité toi si tu colles pas
abandonner c'est sa gaffe au début
c'était un peu dur au début de camp le
confinement commencer nous on essaye de
faire notre maximum
s'il ya des petits défauts on va dire
n'essayez pas de trop critiquer les
agriculteurs on va dire réseau de gaz
feu nourri a zot ses paniers représente
une bonne alternative pendant cette
crise ainsi direction saint louis ou
sous l'impulsion du département les
coopératives se sont coordonnés afin de
répondre à une demande sociale forte
[Musique]
les séries comme partout dans l'île ces
coopératives agricoles centralise plus
de 80 tonnes de fruits et légumes par
semaine ce qui représente 15 mille
panier une prouesse pour cette grande
variété de produits périssables pu
réaliser ces paniers grâce à la
solidarité de l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde agricole
donc notamment par des producteurs que
ce soit via les coopératives ou bien des
producteurs indépendants qui ont décidé
pour la contribution de ces pannes et de
mettre à disposition un tarif
préférentiel
les produits ensuite nous avons mobilisé
un opérateur avec ce dernier puisse
réaliser ses paniers donc ce dernier
s'est chargé d'assurer le recrutement du
personnel nécessaire donc on embauche et
20 personnes supplémentaires qui sont
majoritairement des étudiants dont cnh a
permis aussi indirectement à ces
étudiants d'avoir
de l'argent supplémentaire pour
poursuivre leurs études et ensuite nous
sommes mobilisés auprès des opérateurs
afin de trouver des moyens de transport
notamment des camions frigos afin
d'assurer la livraison dans les 24 mois
d'une manière générale nous avons de la
chance à la réunion c'est que nous
sommes autosuffisants hauteur de 70%
c'est à dire que la production agricole
réunionnaise est capable de nourrir en
totalité
notre population
la machine s'accélère tous se mobilisent
pour sortir des paniers complet pour les
personnes dans le besoin
une partie est livrée aux assistants et
accueillants familiaux et l'autre partie
des camions se dirige vers les ccas des
communes
une chaîne de solidarité qui ne s'arrête
pas nous avons affiché de personnes
vulnérables aux des personnes
effectivement précarité sociale donc à
une première partie de ce fichier qui
est exploité pour la distribution des
paniers
nous avons également un site du ccs et 1
accueille actuellement renforcée depuis
le kobe 19
est-ce qu'il ya pas plus de personnes
projet justement vu le contexte il ya
tout à fait il ya des personnes qui sont
plus fragiles ya des familles qui
avaient l'habitude également de
bénéficier de la restauration scolaire
qui sont actuellement confinés donc avec
plus de difficultés également pour
composer leur repas des familles vous
avez des personnes âgées avec des
craintes également donc effectivement il
ya plus de demandes pour habitude les
agents communaux s'activent alors sur
tout le territoire
une proximité qui compte c'est une
initiative heureuse dans un moment où la
population a besoin d'être soutenu le
département a apporté une aide précieuse
aux personnes âgées aux personnes
vulnérables à travers ses paniers fruits
et légumes et en même temps nous avons
aussi offert au monde agricole la
possibilité d'écouler une partie de leur
production dans une période remplie
d'incertitude nous avons vu au départ de
l'opération beaucoup de marchés forains
qui ne fonctionnait plus beaucoup de
marges et de vos producteurs qui ne se
faisait plus est le département le
conseil départemental à apporter une
solution pour pouvoir écouler une partie
de la production et c'est comme ça que
julie rallo a reçu son panier et surtout
un temps des changes un peu d'humanité
fille
bonjour à tous
[Musique]